à à
anh alo chào bạn
các
bạn nghĩ rõ à
các bạn Mình tập bớt có thừa thôi
các bạn nghe rõ alo
ừ ừ
anh alo alo
à à
có chìa
em vừa rồi 8:40
Ừ anh em bây giờ 40 có bạn em nhắn tin
cho mình là hôm nay không học hả hả anh
Vì thấy mọi khi mình ngon sớm
à à
hai mẹ con muộn hơn giờ mình vẫn là ngon
cho mình chạm nó hơi ngày ngủ tí
ở Đông Hà Kiều Dạo này có thêm em cún
nói vàng hơi bị
sự phát triển hết sức yêu
có sức sống của mình theo kiểu
em chưa quen dậy dỗ lắm nhà nó cứ cậu
chúng con đấy Nó kiểu thường này à
em ở nhà Quý động cả này đừng ủ kinh
không đi
ừ ừ
ờ ờ
để hôm nay mình xin chia sẻ
vài cái trước khi vào buổi học Mình vừa
trả lời Hôm trước
à à
ừ ừ
anh giống như ở cái câu mà không Trước
thề có bạn hỏi
Ừ thì là một sách hả thầy thì à
ừ ừ
Anh bình thường Ai Cập trong video là
mình là mình mà sách một game
ai cũng thầm như là mình từng nói mình
không phải con nhà người ta nhưng mà
mình vẫn khẳng định mình là một thằng
mọt sách
làm nhiều người nghĩ rằng à Nó sát thì
chắc là học giỏi lắm con ơn Vân cái JK
thì đâu phải cứ cắm đầu vào ngồi đọc
nhiều sách thì sẽ học trò đâu đúng không
từ
điển hình giống nhau hồi cấp ba của mình
với cấp 3 mình mình học sinh trung bình
với
lễ hội tắm bùn thì à học sinh tiên tiến
thôi không bao giờ đặc điểm được điểm
tăng cao nên không mơ được học sinh giỏi
à à
A World Cup 2 ngày mai đi học sinh giỏi
nhưng mà đấy cơ à do Cô hiểu Cô
cô chủ nhiệm cô ấy + đĩa đây mà
A Gọi cô đang đợi đừng lên mà với bác
được học sinh giỏi rồi mà được cộng điểm
khi mà khi cấp 3
ẩm thực tế là nhân văn mình không mua
được điểm cao trong mắt các cô bởi vì
không làm theo đồng ý các cô mang tiếng
à cô bảo là làm theo
chú ý hiểu ta nêu cảm nhận của em được
nêu cảm nhận của cô Chứ mày nên mình cảm
nhận của em nữa
Ừ mình mời chị nêu ra đúng cảm nhận của
mình mà không tiêu ý cô thì không mua
điểm cao được ý
sau khi Cái vụ mà sách đấy bản chất là
mình à
em ở nhà mình hồi bé mịn không ai chơi
cùng cũng như là
một mình mẹ con muộn không ai chơi cùng
như là gia đình kìa Để bận rộn hết Em
thử duy nhất chơi của mình thì chắc là
mấy tờ báo và sách giáo khoa
Ừ mẹ cứ kiểu là
ừ ừ
bình thường là sang năm học mới cái thời
mùa hè thì trước khi sang học mới thì
bọn mình định được mua sách giáo khoa
trước để mà xem đọc nghiên cứu ấy thường
ít ông là đọc thực sữa nhưng mình thì
mình đọc bởi vì mình không có
anh Minh không có gì chơi cả mình nuôi
hết sứ báo vẫn là sách ra ở đâu đọc hết
chỉ mỗi tội không đọc sách Toán thì mức
độ vừa đủ vì toàn vô vị đã đọc chả hiểu
cái gì cả như còn sách Văn Sách lịch sử
địa này
ở đây tôi đã hết anh ra là có thể thao
Đọc đôi khi nặn cho nhiệt đâu đứa kia là
đọc Chị đặt cho biết thay các thứ cho
thấy Hay là thôi
có gì Nói chung là việc đọc sách trước
như thế lại khiến lo tôi
khoa học ổn hơn rồi kìa Mình ở Bắc qua
cái đấy trước rồi đúng không
Cũng như là rồi đấy em mà sách được vì
thế trước cửa là có cái thứ tư duy khác
để làm đâu
ba mẹ thì cần kiểu cấm Mày ra ngoài
đường còn ngoài ra mày muốn làm gì thì
làm nhưng trong nhà chẳng có đồ chơi gì
đấy Chả có ai chứ cùng kiểu thế
bố mẹ vợ đánh đồ luôn
nói cho mà hồi đấy con là không kể trong
hôm khai giảng À thì ra là mình cũng à
anh
cũng Kiều Anh phải trốn mẹ đi chơi thôi
ở nhà Nghe lời mẹ thì
Ừ
thì khổ Huế mình sẽ thành thành kỉ mất
anh Ella
lấy lấy tiền ăn mình đi điện tử song đôi
khi là thiếu tiền thì
một loại trộm trộm vì mình Toàn trộm
cùng ngắm cao nhất là 10.000 đấy mình
khá to với một tiếng nhìn như chị Hai
3000đ
anh nói chung là chơi nhưng mà
Anh quay lén We have Mỹ Thế hè thì hiểu
nhà kỷ ở nhà nghỉ
Ừ thì làm BT ý
à à anh nói chung là chơi xong mà Hết
tiền thì còn ngồi đấy ngắm ra chơi cơ mà
suốt cả buổi thì cả sáng từ xa đến tối
anh làm từ sáng đến chiều ở quán net
Ừ thế
Ê mày mà chưa hư không
khi người mẹ tôi luôn nghĩ ra là như thế
sẽ hư các thứ xong rồi về sau cũng đầu
tư máy tính nhà nhà không có mạng à
ừ ừ
Ê mấy ông giỏi toán theo ai tin là ngon
ờ ờ
cho nó một phần phía trước anh từng nói
vụ đấy
ừ ừ
Xin chào bạn Bích Ngân Lê Thị ừ ừ
Ừ cái á
Ừ cái việc giỏi Toán thì quan điểm của
mình phải toán khi mà học
ạ
bây giờ mới thấy cái giáo dục bây giờ
rồi nghe học toán là bây giờ để rèn về
khả năng lập luận tư duy các thứ thứ
đương nhiên là Làm lập trình thì
anh cũng à
anh cũng cần này có tư duy cũng cắt
tương thứ có không sai nhưng mà
ờ ờ cho mình hiện tại Giống như mình
đang dậy các bạn với lịch trình này địa
chỉ các bạn chỉ cần lại tư duy không bị
không bị đi ngược với
số đông được
thì tại sao phải nói có lấy việc các bạn
chỉ cần tư duy giải quyết một bài toán
bình thường
ở lớp trình ý Nó là bình thường anh ví
dụ này theo sinh viên nó dễ hiểu nhé
áo kiểu thay vì bạn tự đứng dậy bạn đi
tìm cách thì để đi tìm đầu tiên đi tìm
cái bình nước này và
A và kiểu lấy ra uống nước thay vì như
thế bạn sẽ viết ra những nòng cốt để mà
kiểu sai khiến máy tính
dụng robot trở lại tự đi lấy nước cho
bạn
Ừ cái bài toán ở đây nó chị Tuyến giản
như thế nó cũng là lập trình
lập trình sẽ sẽ làm những cái động tác
như thế nào được tuyên là sẽ bỏ con
robot Nếu đang ngồi kiểm tra nếu đang
ngồi thì nó đứng dậy này Đấy sau đó thì
ban đầu xác định vị trí của bình nước
này giả sử là
em giả sử là cái bình nước ở đằng sau
thì phải quay lại đằng sau này đúng
không quay lại một chân nào trước dân
vân Thích coi cháy rơi cuối phải hai Cả
hai đều được này xô ngồi bước đến cái
chỗ bình nước thì kiểm tra xem có chững
lại bận gì không Nếu có đi né này không
mình tiếp tục đi Cứ thấy cứ như thế đúng
không là lần
ừ ừ
Ừ Thì chị cái đấy là lập trình nó cái
bài toàn này rất đơn giản như thế
ý nghĩa là bạn có tư duy để làm những
được những kẻ thù Vinh thường ấy mà
không không ấy nỗi là phức tạp ở lên này
như là
Anh Châu
Chồng nói chúng ăn
mày lấy Giờ đơn giản đấy thì các bạn làm
được hiển nhiên các bạn làm được cái đấy
thì các bạn chỉ việc là hay vì các bạn
tự là mình các bạn giờ sẽ thử nói trong
máy tính thì máy tính Lam hộ các bạn đây
là lập trình rồi
ừ ừ
cho nên là mình không nói việc à các bạn
à à Phải chuyên sâu lập trình ở đây
nhưng mà học không cần những chị học
giỏi Toán thì mới làm được chính là em
sai hoàn toàn à
Chỉ còn 2 phút Liệu mình có nói kịp về
quan điểm về hối hận em nghỉ Hôm trước
mình có video trong video Hôm trước mình
có nói vụ là mình cố làm cái gì đó đi
a bít ảnh hưởng đến tương lai để vì sao
mình không ăn
Đó là bài toán lớn hơn ở đây đôi khi ở
các bạn còn bị hiểu nhầm theo kiểu các
bạn sợ làm gì đó ở bề bề so với lợi như
các bạn không thể nghĩ về việc là các
bạn sẽ ân hận khi mà bạn không làm một
cái gì đó
anh giống như ngay bây giờ
khi mà cái cho Bây giờ mình nói luôn
chương trình hợp này đi có một tí gì đó
kiểu các bạn học lập trình này đang miễn
phí này ạ
cho miễn phí qua đó hoàn toàn mở thêm 10
cơ hội một cái cơ hội gì đó
Ừ để cho các bạn có thêm đa dạng hơn mà
ngành ngành cũng như quan điểm khác với
cái ngành này trở lại cũng như khiến đôi
khi sẽ khiến cho
Ô kìa khi bạn sự sử dụng
các công nghệ hay các phần mềm điều hành
về sau mình có hướng dẫn dụ dùng
Facebook tiện hơn lên vân vân Hãy dùng
Google tiện hơn ạ họp tí Bị sẽ chia sẻ
một vài phím tắt
ý của máy tính nào ạ ạ
Ừ thì các bạn sẽ vì sau có thể sẽ ăn thì
các bạn không học từ thế đúng không ạ
anh đấy đấy có điểm mình về em ạ Đó là
đôi khi các bạn sẽ ân hận về việc thứ
các bạn không làm trong quá khứ giống
như kiểu mình đang hạn vì không tỏ tình
cô ấy đã bỏ lỡ cơ hội đấy với Vân hơn là
việc các bạn tỏ tình rồi cho bạn
à à
Ừ thôi bây giờ bắt đầu buổi học đó ngon
có vài bạn hỏi ở đây đi
à à
nhà mình có dậy mô hình như sơ đồ và cơ
sở liệu không Ẩm Thực ra là có mình mình
định dạng Hôm nay mình đã định dậy rồi
nhưng mà
Ừ
nó lại hơi bị chuyên sông tí nên là mình
xin phép qua sẽ dạy cái này khi mà sang
hẳn về bên lập trình đến mua cái vô
trách cụ thể thì mình sẽ dạy
anh nói chung à tiện đây thì mình mình
hộ hôm hôm qua mình có nhận một tin nhắn
của bạn bãi bảo là anh ơi Bây giờ
ạ
Bây giờ
nhiều người đi làm bắt đầu quay lại đi
làm rồi thì việc học 23 tuần nhập ba
buồn một tuần thế này thì ra lại hơn
nhiều còn kết hợp hơn khó cả phải tập
nữa
Cho nên theo mình thì đây cũng là một
cái gì đó cũng đúng
cho nên là
cho nên là mình Chắc là bây giờ mình sẽ
định như nào mình sẽ định là 3 - 3 và
thứ 7
chị sẽ học psql
về cơ bản còn xanh thứ năm như thế này
đúng không giữa tuần
thì mình mùng mình đang định là mình sẽ
dậy xanh mà web cơ bản
ý là Quét các bạn lúc đầu mình sẽ dạy về
fallen về giao diện thì ra là thế Ra
Đương nhiên cũng cũng là dạy cũng là
kiến thức mới cũng bài tập các từ từ
file giao diện thì nó rất hiểu nó rất dễ
và nó kiểu chẳng phải động não mấy
chuyện ra làm mới một tí thôi để các bạn
ạ Cảm thấy nó đỡ quá tải và đỡ bị chán
anh hoặc là
các bạn gái có vẻ đồng tình nó việc đấy
một tuần thì hai buổi thôi
Ừ cái này thì à
Ừ để xem cho tí mình mình xem cấu tạo
được vuốt không
Ừ mình Thư à không ạ đúng Ôi nó kiểu mốt
đi mình sẽ bầu ở trên trên discord nhé
xem là các bạn thích cái nào hơn
Ừ mình đi thoải mái thôi mình à
Chị chuẩn kiểu gì chơi được đúng không ạ
Xin chào bạn về mình không thể trả hết
đấy Tất cả bạn được tham khảo
ừ ừ
khi tôi ngồi ngoài được lịch học trên
trường các thứ thứ thời gian là mình
không lo về các bạn học sinh trường xong
rồi buổi tối học ngay đâu vì mình đã cố
dậy cho nó khá là chậm trong mỗi buổi
nhận ra là các bạn cùng nó mất một tiếng
nghỉ ngơi buổi tối rồi chứ ra kiến thức
này so với kiến thức học trên trường nó
nó nhẹ hơn khá nhiều ấy mình tin là thế
tượng có bạn nói rồi nên là mình rồi
mình không hướng đến ở đây là các bạn
đang học sinh trường bị quá dài mà mình
anh hưởng đến các bạn đang đi làm cơ
Hoặc là các bạn có lịch trùng ngay vào
lớp buổi tối này
ở địa chỉ các bạn đúng à chung mà buổi
học xong rồi còn bạn mất công xem lại
thì các bạn sẽ bị 02 xem mình thấy Xem
trực tiếp nó hay hơn thì xem lại
em cảm thấy cô đơn nghỉ Xem trực tiếp có
bạn bè mà hỏi han các thứ
ừ ừ
Ừ nhưng mà ý mình là việc cả các bạn
cũng có đi làm sao mình có đi làm chứ
mình không Mình không về kiểu người đây
bao hoa như thế này kiếm
kiếm cơm kiểu gì đúng không đi
à à
ở nhà mình nghĩ là tìm sẽ tự tạo phút
xem xem ảnh các bạn thích ca
xe mình nghĩa là Thứ bathứ Bảy là khó ổn
kiểu là một buổi học cuối tuần
Ừ thì thì ít bạn trùng dù cha trùng để
chơi của mày không nuôi con Bộ trưởng ba
thì nó là buổi tầm
sự nghiệp giữa nó không sát với ngày hôm
hôm kia đúng không cái hôm buổi học nó
không bị gần nhau quá in
Ừ ok Nói chung mà lại bị đi hơi
anh đi hơi làm quá mất giờ hầm nó rồi
đúng không ạ
ở đây thì mình sẽ trả lời mấy câu này
nhanh nhỉ
Ờ Ờ
cái này nói chung với nó là khi nào dậy
SQL với một ngôn ngữ lập trình nào đó để
mà
bề mà kiểu nó liên kết với nhau thì bể
màn nhập được dữ liệu vào trong 500 Bây
cái đương nhiên là mình sẽ có kiểu gì
mình học Mỹ học sang Peru lập trình mình
sẽ kết hợp cả hai
bộ phim
em có sách nào về tư duy lập trình Không
thực ra là mình từng mua sách quyển sách
đầu tiên mình mua về Lập trình là của
anh tôi đi cô giáo là Ừ quên xử nam đẹp
có gì khó cái gì
a sách Tôi đi trốn
à à có dạng hình sự đài đây mình quấn
đầu tiên công nghệ thông tin mình mua
nữa cái quần đấy
Ừ tự nhiên là mình đọc hết được còn đấy
Sau đó thì mình đã gần đây mình mua thêm
hai quyển nghe nói là quyển sách đầu
giường của lập trình viên nào phải có nó
là lin Cốt và giờ nincada hai cái quyển
giờ Lim Cốt và clean coder một cài clean
cốt tức là mã sạch dịch ra thế một kỳ
Linh cu đơ là người gõ mã sạch được Nếu
dịch ra không là như thế nhưng mà thật
sự là nó bằng tiếng Anh mình đặt đặt về
Ừ
bắt fake các bạn nên mua bàn bây giờ có
rất nhiều bạn in Và thậm chí có dịch
gì thì đương nhiên thực ra mình hạn chế
mi nhá Đọc dịch của với bia dịch đôi khi
nó chẳng hiểu gì chẳng hiểu gì là về
ngôn ngữ lập trình mặt không Linh rực rỡ
lắm nhưng mà
anh có nhiều bạn về chắc ở lậu à Kiểu
cái thấy của người ta hỗ trợ Y5 mình giá
rẻ rất nhiều Mình mình tôn trọng tác giả
thì mình đặt hai quyền đấy mất hơn ba
triệu cho dù là mình bật mình mấy vài
trang xin lỗi các bạn giờ gần đây mình
không còn lòng nó xương màu sắc nữa mình
chuyển qua một mạng xã hội với một ghê
một đi
Ừ nhưng mà thực sự để 2 quyển này vẫn
được tính hay cuốn gối đầu của dân Công
Nghệ Thông Tin ở cửa là đấy thì các bạn
vừa đọc vừa nghe qua cụ là khi nó cốt mã
sạch ngon và cốt sao cho nó dễ nhìn dễ
đọc và lin Corner người gõ mã phải sạch
tức là người đấy phải có tự cây sắc đấy
em chứ gì đấy em
à Còn những quyển sách khác thì mình
mình chưa mua nên là mình không thể
khuyên các bạn được nhưng mà mình từng
nói về cái vụ nó giống như khóa với Nếu
nó miễn phí hoặc là nó cho các bạn đọc
trước như các bạn kiểu gì như là qua bơ
đầy sách ra cũng đầy có review này xong
rồi cũng đưa nó cho xem trước một vài
trang này đương nhiên là mấy cái đấy có
gì ở đó chỉ ra những cái hay thôi còn
những cái rồi mình không biết nhưng mình
Chính vì những ngày hai đứa mình đã qua
mình cảm thấy hay và mình hiệu thực sự
mình mình nên cân nhắc đúng không Em
đừng có kiểu chạy theo phong trào làm gì
cả
ở tấm nhựa cái quyền lin cốt của mình
vừa nói nó bằng tiếng Anh nếu mà các bạn
thì anh chưa đủ tốt cũng như là các bạn
không hẳn chuyên sâu về bên màn này thì
các bạn được cả không cần mua đúng không
về muộn
em về mấy cái vụ mà mày chắc là mình để
buổi sau sẽ trả lời vậy
a Project ngày xưa của thầy đi cái này
khá hay này
ừ ừ
nhà mình có nên cấp cho mọi người xem
luôn về những cái cốt mình đã chia sẻ để
tạo động lực ra các bạn không nhỉ
Ừ anh thử nhé Hiện tại hôm nay cài càng
ít đi đúng không
À hôm trước là
120 thong100 còn hôm nay còn 80 ứng dụng
dẫn chết rồi à
Ừ
mình đầu tiên à cốt của mình lưu ở trên
trang trí thấp
ở đây ký Tháp của mình mà mình có tạo
cài á
cách tạo cái gọi cái cho là một cái thư
mục đi là chưa tin côngty ở đấy là mình
đã tạo cái này từ lâu rồi 4 năm rồi lại
bốn năm rồi rồi đấy là mình thần tượng
mới cái anh là trong utyt này chia sẻ
rất nhiều tool Facebook Sau đó mình cũng
học lò rồi mà tìm hiểu về tung Facebook
Cái Dư thứ rồi chia sẻ chia sẻ các tool
này lên chi nhóm của mình lần cuối mình
chia sẻ khá lâu rồi này có các bạn đang
thấy hay có cái là 23 tháng hay thậm chí
có cái lên ba bốn năm rồi
Đã lâu lắm không bị không động là màn
này đi
nhưng mà
mình đang muốn nói qua các bạn cái vụ là
là cái kiến thức các bạn học các bạn thể
làm những gì đúng không kiểu thế mình sẽ
Đề cập về cái vụ mà mình đưa cái khoe
khá nhiều Điền hình các sinh viên mình
nữa nó cái vụ này
thì tại sao tự nhiên lại khoe cái này
đầu tiên vì à trình Cái này lại là cái
mà mình đã từng là định mà để đi tán gái
à
Ừ cái này là mình ngồi gõ các bạn kéo
xuống cuối nha các bạn thế là 49 dòng
đúng không
a49 nòng cốt
ở cây cái này để làm gì Cái này là tool
để mà ngồi spam
à thả phẫn nộ và cả tháng đây Hà phẫn nộ
này hay thả bất kì ghê cái biểu tượng
cảm xúc gì
Chỉ với một người bất kỳ
Ừ rồi đấy mình làm cái tôi này bằng nút
phát đầu ngoài còn ếch xanh có hai ông ở
bên cạnh một ông đang ngồi chơi Liên
Minh mùa đông mà ngồi chơi cho ta
cả hai ông đều lắm Đang ngồi chơi tự
nhiên phải quay sang nhìn mình cũng bởi
vì thế Thằng này mở Notepad lên ngồi gõ
cốt như thật như kiểu này em mới hack
cái Facebook con này kia ạ đấy à Ừ cái
soi mình
đương nhiên là mình mạnh cốt này xong
hết rồi sao mình thay cái cái Token
topken thì ạ để các bạn hiểu rõ Ken là
gì thì
khi chờ cuối buổi này đi với buổi này
mình sẽ dùng trình cái video của anh
Mạnh Tuấn mà giải thích các bạn cái tóc
em nó là gì ạ
em và nói chung mình dùng cho Ken bản
thân đã cái nó như quỳnh chìa khóa với
cái nick của mình
ạ sau đó đi thay ID của cái Facebook của
người mà người bị hại người mình muốn
bão không Chị sang cái bạn gái kia mình
thay vào Sau đó mình ngồi Tam phẫn nộ
toàn bộ những bài đang cũ của bạn đấy để
hết lên rồi đấy
để gây sự chú ý
điều khiển có ông không nên chơi cách
này thì nhớ dễ bị Facebook chặn thích
chạm từng tác một khoảng một thời gian
không thì bạn để chạm mình
nhưng mà nó làm cái gì ở hai mà đúng
không
hay chỉ một ví dụ thôi
i took a là mình từng làm rất nhiều tool
giống như là gì rất nhiều ông ở đây làm
mà bên A chạy quảng cáo hay vân vân vân
Ừ qua đây toàn nhờ tôi làm cái tu này
hoặc gà kiểu có tool à
em xóa hết tất cả bạn bè è Xóa hết tất
cả bài đăng
trong một khoảng thời gian nào đó chợ
hoa cà đổi hết tất cả bài đang từ trạng
thái công khai sanh thành một mình tôi
hay thành bạn bè nhưng mà trong một
khoảng thời gian
thằng Facebook mà có cái vụ đấy nhưng mà
nó chỉ đổi về
ở trạng thái bạn bè hay chứ không đổi về
trạng thái mình tôi này không nói chung
mà hỏng Facebook nó không tiện được
ừ nóng hơn to làm thì đưa mình cần tránh
nghe theo ý mình
ý mình muốn đổi
có rất nhiều bài năng phải đến có ông
Một ngày đang tâm trúc bài vừa phải nhìn
mấy nhưng mày ăn rồi đúng không Mình
muốn đổi vài nghìn cái mày đang trong
khoảng mốc thời gian yêu của yêu cô bé
kia nhưng bây giờ chia tay rồi đấy ạ
Mình không muốn xóa đi a ra xưởng mình
xóa đi cho nữa có ông thì chơi mẹo là
ông ấy đang hết sư đó trong một album
Ông ấy chỉ làm sao Boonie xong
Hỏi đổi tên album Thành kỷ niệm cũ hãy
kiểu thế
ừ ừ
anh nói chết làm bàn quá Nói chung à đây
Tôi khỏe cao ông Thế thì tạo động lực
cho không ạ học học lập trình xong có
thể làm những gì Thôi em hơi bị lan man
thôi à
Ừ rồi thôi mình nhảy sang ôn tập và
ôn tập bài hôm trước và xanh Bộ hôm nay
nhé
anh không Cốt thì đừng như cốt của mình
là pê thở ra các bạn học lập trình xong
thì các bạn cốt bằng được bất kỳ cái gì
cũng được
ở đây cái bài hôm trước
ừ ừ
đã tạo cơ sở liệu để lưu thông tin kinh
doanh thông tin kinh doanh của một cửa
hàng bản chất là là nó cần lưu lại kiểu
thông tin khách hàng khá nhiều như hôm
trước hôm trước mình thấy có bạn bình
luận ở đây bà Mình chỉ cần lưu mỗi họ và
tên được thiếu đây mình sẽ thử làm nhé
ừ ừ
ờ ờ
ở Sydney
ăn mì gõ đây trước mà có bạn quen này
ghê mình sẽ có khách hàng này
anh có mã này có tên này
ạ sau đó đi mình ra xưa mình có sản phẩm
có mã này tên này
à Hôm trước có bạn làm như thế này nhưng
thôi ta làm mình không nên chỉ như thế
này thông tin khách hàng đôi khi nó sẽ
có cả họ tên nè Số điện thoại này chán
thế
bình thường là nó đôi khi sẽ thêm tuổi
giới tính dễ xưng hô này mà chính này
sinh cũng chỉ dễ xưng hô
à à
A
và thức chứa email cho tự thử đúng không
bộ đề thi thoảng sman quảng cáo
cô gái kiêu thế
ở quê quán Tùy các bạn thích thì có bạn
thì lưu em
mã sản phẩm thì mình sẽ lưu cái gì sản
phẩm mình ngoài mã tên đã mẹ dùm
anh Run tí bạn à Không biết các bạn nhìn
có rõ không
anh ạ
à à
à
Có chứ các bạn đưa công ty khách hàng
này thì các bạn span span Quảng cảm đấy
sự thật Bạn lưu thông tính cái nhà để
mình tính mua
à
à mã tên rồi
ở mô tả đi Giá
em chẳng hạn thế
em tính ăn phải có những cái này có bạn
thì bà lưu lại Ạ số lượng còn trứng kho
số lượng nhiệt về cái từ từ ra cái này
bài toán nó khó hơn Minh ký sẽ không
được gặp ra tại sao khó hơn mới việc các
bạn lưu lại số lượng thì về Khi mà các
bạn đặt hàng trong các bạn phải kiểm tra
xem số lượng là con còn đủ để một các
bạn đã thấy không và khó hơn em nhưng sẽ
không đề cập ở đây
xổ xổ số thành thông chí khách hàng ở
trại vào như thế này đúng không và bảng
hóa đơn và hóa đơn tự nhiên hóa đơn mình
sẽ có lưu mã khách hàng
anh
thay vì mình phải mất công lưu toàn bộ
những thông tin này trong hóa đơn thì
mình sẽ lưu một mã khách hàng là được
rồi sẽ có đầy đủ tất cả những thông tin
này đúng không
mà tán nhưng mà
ở những bài toán ở đây là
Ừ mình cũng phải lưu lại là mát sản phẩm
được mình biết được là bạn ấy sẽ đặt cái
gì đúng không
ở bảng xếp hạng thế
Ừ Rồi
sau đó đi Ví dụ khách hàng một này nghĩa
này Long này 123
mẹ mày ra xử lưu lại giới tính là Nam
nhé
chị đã sửa ngày đúng 001 01 1973
anh
lắm chẳng hạn thế à
số một này bút này à
à
bút của Trung Quốc trả
giá á
à à
ở
đây giá 10k nhé
Áo kiểu kiểu như nai về chưa em
đề thi Giáo sử là mình mình muốn mua hai
cái bút đúng không Thì mình không thể
mình mình sẽ lập lại cái này thành hai
phát như này thì tao nó không tốt
cả hai ông bà thường là mình sẽ lưu lại
mình giờ sửa mình sẽ
Hình như lại cả ngày mua trả
Ê
mày mua cho ạ
Ừ thì các bạn sẽ thấy da sửa ngày hôm
nay ngày 30 tháng 9 em ạ
thì các bạn lưu lưu cả
2021 cho là như này
à à
hôm nay của mình đang Không nhìn thì
đúng được theo kiểu dạng ngay các bạn
đang thấy nó là thế bởi vì sao mà bia
cái lưu định dạng mà mình đang là pho
mát date của mình lại đang hiểu của
tháng trước
ba mẹ ba bể ngày trước nhà nó không hiểu
đâu xa mình có thể chỉnh lại nó nó như
thể bấm đầy chính ngon
Ừ
anh trung hòa các cột này mình trên lại
cái format nó được
anh về như này cẩn ạ
anh nhìn họ không nhận diện à Cái này
nếu thế bạn ở trình chuyến sau hơn là
format nó là 52 ngày 2 ngày tháng năm gì
đó Cái này thôi nó liên quan bánh xe
mình không đề cập nhắc
lại khái à thông tin như này chưa ạ
Ừ đúng rồi có bạn trả lời đúng rồi đó là
hay vì mất công nhiều như này đúng không
có ba nghị mình mua bao nhiêu cái bút
mình không phải lặp lại mấy lần ngay
đúng không Mình sẽ thay bằng cái gì mình
thay bằng cột số lượng nữa đúng không
Đây là sư mình cho ngày mua để lên đầu
đi là sự thế Mình sẽ cho cô số lượng Đây
là hai trả nợ là xong chưa
Ừ
thì các bạn thấy Ok như này thì bài toán
nó sẽ
chị sẽ dễ hơn một tí bao giờ sử mình cho
số lượng hạn chế lên 20 ạ thì vẫn không
sao cả đúng không Nó vẫn đúng nhưng ở
đây lại phát sinh thêm nữa đó là
em hẹn nhỡ đâu Mình mua hay là
là cái quyển sách trở lại ngon
anh sex của giá sách của Harry Potter
anh chưa Thế 500 càng trở lại khi các
bạn lại thấy là nó vẫn lặp lại bản ghi ở
đây nếu mà các bạn đang theo quy tắc như
này
đây số lượng và mình chỉ mua được mục
quyền trường ạ kiểu như thế này các bạn
thấy em nó lặp lại như thế này thì là
không tốt như kiểu là nó lặp lại hai cái
trường này
anh nói chung cái đó là cái này nó tính
hay hóa đơn mất rồi Các bạn đi siêu thị
đi mua sắm gì đó thì các bạn mua bao
nhiêu chăng nữa họ vẫn sẽ chị in vào
trong một cái hóa đơn các bạn in 1 hóa
đơn thôi Đúng không Một hóa đơn nên nó
sẽ gồm nhiều sản phẩm chứ không phải đã
nó tách ra làm cũng mỗi một sản phẩm là
một hóa đơn như này đúng không
Ừ Thì bài toán ở đây nó là mối quan hệ
cái này là
mối quan hệ giữa hóa đơn và sản phẩm nó
là nn về chưa
Anh ở xã Nhân ái mình sẽ ghi lại các bạn
dễ hình dung nhé á ờ ờ
ê nờ hóa đơn
chứa n sản phẩm
tại sao tự nhiên lại còn ở hóa đơn ở đây
thì rõ ràng mình vừa nói một hóa đơn
chứa nhiều sản phẩm cơ mà đúng không làm
gì có chuyện mua sản phẩm lại thuộc
nhiều hóa đơn được cái bút của mình có
phải dùng chung không để bán chung cho
cái ông kia được đúng không
nữ sinh viên bị từng thắc mắc câu đấy ví
dụ Giả sử mình bán cho mình có bút rồi
đúng không Tại sao thằng kia nó nó lại
hưởng cái bút mình à Tại sao một cái bút
lại có thể thuộc được nhiều hóa đơn
Cái này là không các bạn bán là không
phải bán đất không ạ Không phải là các
bạn bán cái bút xong mà người khác không
mua được cái loại bút này nữa Không cái
này ra nào chính xa là mặt hàng thôi Nó
là một mặt hàng sản phẩm các bạn bán
thì các bạn có rất nhiều cái bút và các
bạn bán bút xong cái mặt hàng này nó vẫn
còn để các bạn kinh doanh và mặt hàng
đấy hoàn toàn thể nằm trong một hóa đơn
rất nhiều hóa đơn khác được chưa Thế nên
là
ở đây vi chuẩn ra là nó mặt hàng sản
phẩm thì nó ổn hơn và đấy thì tức là mụn
sẵn một mặt hàng sản phẩm đương nhiên có
thể thuộc được nhiều hóa đơn rồi Đúng
chưa Thế nên là đây mình sẽ
em phải tạo ra tắt mà ra thành một bản
trung gian lưu lại thông tin của kẹo hóa
đơn và cả sản phẩm mình sẽ thử đặt tên
nó là hóa đơn chi tiết này
hóa đơn chi tiếp
mà mình sẽ lưu lại mã hóa đơn
kèm theo mã sản phẩm vào trong này
Anh ấy thì có bạn sẽ thấy đương nhiên ở
trong này Bây giờ nó sẽ
Anh xóa cái này đi này
ở đây
Khi
mà mình sẽ có thêm cuộn mã ở đây rồi ạ
thật sự một này Xóa thông tin này đi nó
số lượng đây Các bạn thấy nó sẽ sai số
lượng này sẽ xóa đi này
Khi mà mình sẽ Tống Xá bên này là mới
đúng này
là sử đây mã hóa đơn là một mã sản phẩm
là bột nhé
bộ mã hóa đơn vẫn là một và mã sản phẩm
là hai Số lượng là một đó như này là
được các bạn sẽ thấy là
anh ở đây đấy Mình làm lại các bạn dễ
hình dung
chợ hoa sửa bây giờ Giả sử có thêm một
bạn khác đi
anh Tuấn Anh trở lại ngon
thông tin này bỏ qua đi Trung Hoa kiều
sự ba bà đây là
sổ lại
xe tải chuyển nhà giá là 200K nào
em và gia sửa là đương nhiên là bây giờ
anh Tuấn Anh ấy mua thì hoàn toàn không
thể ghi vào hóa đơn của mình được đúng
không Không chuyện tính chung như thế
mày giờ trước chả là mình sẽ có tạo thêm
cái nữa mình mãi khách hàng là hai có
thể cùng ngày hôm nay hôm sau cả không
sao nhưng mà mã hóa đơn khác cô ấy là sự
anh đầy mua kiểu khác đi anh ấy mua sách
vì xấu hổ rồi em ạ ai mua đây 10 quyển
và
để sổ này không nắm quyền được hạn như
thế này
ý là được đúng không cái này được không
ừ ừ
anh chị bài toán ở đây các bạn sẽ thấy
tê tranh thủ bây giờ đã hỏi lại cho các
bạn Các bạn xem các bạn có đang tập
trung không nhé
Ừ cái bảng này đi
ở bản này
từ khóa chính là gì là Cột nào
ở bảng nào cũng nên cầu phá trinh đúng
không Chị sẽ các bạn bảo hóa đơn chi
tiếp hóa chính
cô nàng cụt Nam
à hay là những con nào không
Ừ rồi 100 mua pin lên đến 130
à mà trong Mong trả lời tôi câu đấy
à à
em có bạn đang vẫn còn bị nhầm nghe đúng
không
Ừ Ok có vẻ nhiều bạn trả lời đúng nhưng
mà cũng có vẫn có bạn trả lời bị nhầm nó
thì hơn mình sẽ giải thích
Ừ thì hôm trước mình có nói cách đơn
giản nhất đôi khi là các bạn chưa biết
thì bạn có thể thử thôi đúng không thử
thì
Khi nào
ông ngồi ông kia nói mã sản phẩm giá
khóa ngoại mà Thì đấy là cái sai à ít
nhất là 2 cái cột này cột mạng là khó
ngoại thôi đúng không cột này là khoáng
ngoại nối bảo hóa đơn và cột này là cuộc
hóa ngoại nói đến cái này nó không phải
là khóa phụ bởi vì không có khái niệm
hóa phụ nếu mà các bạn và là vừa là phá
chính vừa nó khóa phụ thì nghe nó còn vô
lý nhưng con vừa là khóa chính mà vừa là
khó ngoại thì không có gì sai cả thì
chưa nó không đi sai cả
sau khi kích hoạt chính ở đây không
Trước nghị nói nó bản chất hóa chính là
gì và chính là để tránh việc lập lại dữ
liệu đúng không để nó là duy nhất mà
đúng không Thì đây các bạn sẽ thấy mã
hóa đơn ở đây nếu ra sự mỗi cột họ mã
hóa đơn là
khi nào khóa chính thì cột này các bạn
thế Cuộc này đang lập Điệp lại này thì
nó lỗi rồi đúng không tương tự là
chị làm mã sản phẩm mà khóa chính tự
thôi đúng không Thì cái sản phẩm Thứ hai
này Nó là loại nó lại lỗ mất rồi Đúng
chưa
Vì thế nên là hai cục này là khóa chính
em xem có được không nha bây giờ sở là
anh Tuấn Anh ấy tự nhiên này mua thêm
một quyển sổ nữa thì thay vì mình mất
công và nhập vào là mã hóa đơn là hai mã
sản phẩm là ba xong một số lượng là một
thì thế này nó sẽ báo lỗi vì hai cái này
nó giặt lại nói chung với hai thằng trên
này đúng không Thì số lượng và phải tăng
lên chẳng hạn thế số lượng nó sẽ tăng
lên và 6 trở lại thì nó mới đúng được
chưa
Ừ thì hai cột này nên là khóa chính
anh cũng cũng có bạn hồi trước mình toàn
thấy ra các bạn không biết đánh khóa
chính các bạn một là tạo thêm cái cốt mã
tự động tăng ở đây thưa cụt mã tự động
tăng đây là Thanh Nga thưa mà nó không
nó không giúp để kiểm tra xem cái cái
đơn này có bị lặp sản phẩm này không về
mà tăng số lượng lên đúng không Cũng
giống như là có bạn thì cho cả 3 cột này
là hoa chính luôn em ạ Thế lại say bởi
vì như mình vừa nói thì nếu là sửa mình
nhập lại mã hóa đơn mã sản phẩm ở đây số
lượng thay đổi như này thì không báo lỗi
vì số lượng nó có bị bị lặp lại đâu đúng
không Thế không đúng
ở tại Đấy chữa bài hôm trước
về chưa
Ê bà chắc là mình sẽ
thì
mình sẽ thổ
cách tạo bảng tặng bạn mày ra cho nó thì
hôm nay mình không chỉ mỗi hướng dẫn các
bạn việc tạo cơ sở dữ liệu như này sẽ
hướng dẫn các bạn về những câu lệnh mà
Việt kiều để mà nối những cái bàn lại
với nhau để mình thì ra kết quả
Nhưng mà trước hết thì mình làm dễ chút
đã cái này thì ra là cái này các bạn
thấy bún bảng hơi khó mình sẽ chỉ lại
dậy Các bạn thấy hay bạn trước thôi
cho
nên là mình sẽ dạy các bạn về sinh viên
với lớp khá la cơ bản trước mình sẽ mình
sẽ giải quyết và toàn là như sau sự là
thi công bảng đơn nhiên à Hôm trước mình
có nói kìa
11 Lớp chứa
ở một lớp
chứa n sinh viên đúng không Và Giả sử
bài toán ở đây là sinh viên chỉ thuộc
một lớp đó nhé cho nó đơn giản nhé
cho sinh viên thuộc nhiều lớp thì nó nó
là nn với nhau với lại khó
đề thi nếu mà một lớp chứa n sinh viên
như thế này thôi các bạn sẽ
chị sẽ thấy là mình sẽ phải tạo bằng lớp
trước và lớp sẽ thằng cha bằng sinh viên
chưa
ở dạng xoáy đầu mày đi đấy à
một mình à
bí quyết table of đi
mình sẽ có mã
in pp
tên nv thứ hai là mẹ
nó luôn và muốn nick luôn đi tên tên lớp
thì không Linh chung đúng không chồng
thì cho ca nó không có nghĩa gì lắm mình
mất công tạo hai lớp rồi nói chung
có
20.000 cho nó cột mày à
Ừ rồi đúng
ạ sau đó đi mình tạm bảng sinh viên này
ừ ừ
khi
tân sinh viên có thể chồng nhưng mà
không Để chồng nó sau đó đi mình sẽ có
giới tính là ạ
Việt kiều a
bit
more money I
Á đù đúng rồi nó luôn đi mình cho nó đi
fo là là sự không được ạ mà để nữ chẳng
hạn đúng
A và mình sẽ cột mã lớp là kiểu in
ở hai cột này nó phải từng nhau thì kiểu
dữ liệu thì mình mới nói khó ngoại được
thì sẽ con kia nó
bạn lớp
tùy cho rằng
mạng lớp lại cột mảng nào thế
ta có bảng Sinh viên là ngon tình cảm
rốt mà đã à
đầu
tiên mình sẽ in shop nó ngon tinh sớm
lớp trước đã sẽ có tên Zalo cho sửa là
mình có hai lớp và lập trình
và
an toàn thông tin đúng không
Nhà có hai lớp
Anh pha mịn có sinh viên là xử thế mình
có sinh viên a a
thì mình cứ xe lách lại cái bằng lớp
trước lại nhé
Sao không lớp để các bạn dễ Hình dung là
mình đang có những cái mã nào đúng không
Có ai có mã 1 và 2 đúng không
Và mình sẽ
in sơ sinh viên với tính để vô rồi Nhưng
mà lớp phải không đi vô à
à à
em
không có Kris database
ờ ờ thì ra là mình đang dùng cái Master
người ta không tốt thì ra thường là mình
sẽ nhớ dùng could tay nhưng dạo này mình
hơi lười mình mình sử dụng luôn là
Master
em mặc định Mà nó sẽ có một cái đó TP
Master II
mà mong cha mình sẽ dùng cái defoe đi
Đúng không các bạn biết được thu là gì
mạ lớp và một thì mình sẽ yêu mình họp
lớp lập trình lại
ừ ừ
Anh Tuấn chẳng hạn đúng không
em một này
Ừ anh ấy cũng học lập trình đi là xử thế
bà là Tuấn hacker ạ thì
ở lại học bên
ý an toàn thông tin thế nào sau đây có
các bạn thế có ba sinh viên đúng không
Hai sinh viên ở lớp thứ nhất và một sinh
viên lớp thứ hai em ạ Nhìn xem này rồi
sao con sinh viên đấy
Ừ thì mình sẽ ra được thông tin như thế
này nhưng mà ở đây Các bạn thấy là đi
kèm lớp 1 và lớp 2A Ừ thì các bạn đôi
khi không nhớ được là lớp 1 là gì lắp
hay là gì mà ngon mình cần nối màng lớp
này mày mình lấy thấy tên của cái lớp
đấy
mình sẽ làm như sau
thì mình sẽ là có khái niệm là do I
I love
dựa trên cột gì cũng cho mình còn nói
qua bộ đấy rùa dậy trên cột mã này bằng
sinh viên
anh gửi mã lớp này như này
anh chạy nhé
Khi nào ra chưa các bạn thấy seexi ở đây
rồi đang lấy tất cả cột của cả 2 3 và nó
sẽ ưu tiên là lấy theo bảng nào mình gọi
trước là chính xác ở bên trái bên trái
mình sẽ khái niệm Tại sao tự nhiên mình
nói với bên trái ở đây Khái niệm và
thằng nào gọi trước thì sẽ lên trái Tôi
nhớ bạn và rõ ràng đây bên trên bên dưới
mà nó ngon ra bản chất là với với bọn nó
thì đương nhiên nó phải Chung Một Dòng
Như này nhưng mình lại inter xuống dòng
nhưng thực ra thay vẫn ở bên trái nhé
Vào thay đổi gọi trước cái này được gọi
sau đúng không
Thế thì thằng anh sẽ được đứng như sẽ
hiển thị ra trước đúng không sau đó đến
được hàng ngày chưa đi và cái này Hôm
trước mình nói về cái choi cũng có bạn
hỏi đó là do này nó lại in Android hay
là gì thì cái vụ in New York các thử thử
thì bây giờ mình xin phép mình cho các
bạn xem cái ảnh này đã
Ừ thế bạn hình dung qua A
anh cái ảnh này à Hôm trước mình cũng
mới trả lời câu hỏi của có bạn nghe thắc
mắc về do thì mình sẽ thường ngay cho
các bạn xem cái ảnh này thì đây
em có hai cái hai cái mà mình sẽ không
học
đó là hai cái dưới này
thì mình sẽ không dậy các bạn với cái
này
Ô kìa Cái này không có trong máy queo
như mình sẽ không dậy
chỉ còn 5 ngày hơn ở trên thì các bạn à
thì các bạn sẽ sẽ được học về chưa
ở
album ảnh gái hở ngực album
ở đây ảnh rồi mà ông ông xoay được đề ra
thành hơn nữa đấy linh tinh
ừ ừ
Ừ
đấy thì cái nhìn hình như này thì ra các
bạn sẽ thấy là cái cái thằng a này tất
cả hàng mà được khai báo trước là thằng
nào bên trái cái thằng B sẽ thằng nằm
bên phải đơn giản thế thôi chưa Và chị
cái roi vừa rồi mình dạy các bạn ấy thì
roi cho này chính là enjoyed ở đây đây
à thực ra thì trong trường hợp này thì
các bạn thấy là là thứ quá à thực ra là
nếu mà các bạn khai báo khóa ngoại như
thế này
à Khỉ tức và thằng sinh viên phải luôn
Nằm phải luôn nằm trong lớp
em phải có một cái lớp mà Nó tồn tại thì
thì mới đưa không sẽ Báo lỗi chưa sẽ báo
lỗi Tức là sao mình sẽ vẽ bằng tên có
thể hơi sống thì các bạn xem quay nhé
em thật sự đây Thằng A này
em xấu ạ bây đây anh Tuấn anh nhé Anh
sữa đây Thằng này chính xác là đây Hoàng
sinh viên đi xử lý sinh viên nhé về chưa
ở đây sinh viên này chưa sinh viên để
khai báo trước thì các bạn sẽ nghĩ là
thằng lớp có sẽ ở nhà không thằng lớp
chẳng ạ gì chưa
anh không đúng đúng rồi con vòng tròn
tại sao mình quên nhé Xin lỗi cho bạn ạ
Ừ ok
à quên quên
Anh không ngờ vẽ chữ kêu tiện hơn mà
cô sinh viên à à
à à
Ừ ông thấy kiểu này có bất tiện không
ở đó và các bạn sẽ thấy đây ở lớp này
em chẳng hạn như thế này
Em hãy kiểu khiến nhanh hơn
Ừ
thôi nói chung à các bạn sẽ thấy cái
đoạn D3 đoạn này đậu xanh
Ừ
cái vừa nãy cái vẽ vẽ vậy Anh vừa nãy
rồi
Vì vậy bạn cứ nãy to lắm rồi
à à
Ừ chúc đại khái đoạn này đúng không Lại
các đoạn này nó sẽ là cái là cái giao
nhau của giữa sinh viên và lớp đúng
không ạ
xe tải
Ừ cái này là cái giao nhau đúng chưa ạ
ẩm thực tế là thằng kia cái này nó còn
đang hơi sai sai tại sao sai bởi vì khi
mà các bạn khai báo cái phone key này nó
ràng buộc là sinh viên phải luôn nằm
trong lớp rồi
Em ngủ chưa nghe khái niệm về luôn nằm
trong lớp thì ra là các bạn sẽ thấy đâu
la la thằng thằng sinh viên nó đã phải
luôn Nằm ở đây rồi đấy
về chưa vì nó không có khái niệm sinh
viên nào nằm ngoài ngay đâu Đây nhá đầy
mình thử giải thích cụ thể hơi nhé bạn
nhé Sẽ không có sinh viên nào nằm ngoài
này chưa Không sinh viên không nằm trong
nắp không nằm trong lớp nào đúng không
đấy cũng tương tự thế Ở đây sẽ có 3 sinh
viên đang nằm trong 2 lớp được chứ gì
A
và play đang xử với mình thử Insert một
lớp mới không có sinh viên nào vẫn
Insert được mà đúng không Thì ra xử lý
rất là thêm một lớp nữa đi
cho mình mình không sửa cái này để tí
các bạn xem các bạn dễ hình dung nhé
Đang sửa lớp này lớp à
thứ Hai cơ mũi tràn đi à
ta kiểm nha rất là lớp mày có bạn thấy
mình mới xuất hàng ra là không
bộ đồ màu
anh không Mình mình chính vì mình không
muốn dùng đổ màu gì mình muốn ghi chữ
lên đây mà thấy tớ bảo rồi tôi ngay từ
đầu dưới định chỉ dùng mẽ thôi Có phải
Dễ không ạ
Ừ
đấy thì chả sự mới thêm một lớp mới này
không có sinh viên nào không thì đây sẽ
ra một lớp chị chưa
các bạn sẽ thấy
sinh viên chứ sao nó không nói chuyện
sinh viên nào không
nằm ngoài cái lớp này nó sẽ lỗi ngay là
sử bây giờ mình không thể in shop một
bạn sinh viên
này Xóa ID
lại Long này đi phụ bỏ qua rồi tí không
có tâm giới tính cái này nữa đi
nhà sư mạ lớp là 100.000
tên Long Sky ạ đấy
anh không sốt được nó sẽ báo lỗi mà liên
quan mình rằng Bộ khánh Ngoại nên không
chuyện không sinh viên nào hoa cá thậm
chí là mình xóa luôn cả mã lớp này đi
này à
anh Alo sao mà lớp cho - màn hình chưa
chạy được Đúng rồi Nhưng mà trường hợp
này mình không gian buộc à
Ừ ừ đúng rồi sinh viên
à
mình Mình quên mất cái cột đá mã lớp của
mình có thể Mun Ừ nếu ăn luôn gì đúng
không có một sinh viên nằm ngoài Ok thế
thì cũng được Được đấy Ở đây là nó không
cho tôi sửa đây tôi sẽ ghi đè lên Kệ nó
nhé
Anh xin lỗi các
ừ ừ
À mình quên mình quên là sinh viên của
mình có thể à
à à
Á có thị lùn mã lớp thường mình không
cho luôn mà lớp đâu bởi vì rõ ra các bạn
làm gì có chuyện mà bây giờ ông ông Khi
mà nhập học vào Ông ông kiểu gì cũng sẽ
có một lớp mà đúng không
từ hạt làm gì có chuyện mà ông không nằm
trong mưa lớp nào đúng không
anh điều đấy Thực ra nó là sai nhưng mà
may mà mình mình vừa thêm lại là không
là đây không còn mất luôn thấy là vẫn
thêm được sinh viên không nằm trong lớp
nào Okay đúng không
đấy thì đây sẽ là ba sinh viên và sinh
viên đúng
có hai lớp chưa hay lớp xấu vãi an đại
khai mấy ông hình dung mà đúng không Đấy
một lớp thì có
không có không có sinh viên nào và một
sinh viên không nằm trong lớp nào Ok
đúng không
ở bờ kỳ quan trọng là bài toán mà bây
giờ tại sao tự nhiên nãy giờ mình phải
đề cập tất cả những cái vụ đấy đây Bơ
Giả sử là mình sẽ áp dụng theo chị nghĩ
ảnh nữa thôi chính ngân hàng ngày các
bạn đang xem
anh mới trả lời với mình nhé ra xử A là
A là sinh viên b là lớp
khi bơm trả lời câu hỏi cho mình
cho đến giờ lại ngồi trả lời câu hỏi rồi
em lấy ra
ở đầu tiên thì
đầy ra
cho
sinh viên
thông tin sinh viên
đi
kèm lớp học của họ Ừ thì là hình nào bây
giờ sự đây là đây hình
122345 thì chưa trái phải giữa trái phải
Ừ thì sẽ ra hình nào thì các bạn phải
trả lời sẽ
ừ ừ
à à
Ừ
khi nào mình sẽ giúp được cái câu chuyện
ở đây đúng
Ồ thông tin sinh viên kèm lớp học của họ
ở đây là một này hay này 3 4 năm trước
Ê
mèo
xong mấy ông trả lời sai hết vậy Alo Ôi
Có đúng một người đúng á ơi có vai
trường
vì thế sẽ giờ rồi tại sao cái ông này
đang chọn hình hình hình một vậy đừng
giải thi cho tốt
ừ ừ
Ừ
đúng rồi
bộ phim
399 thì kia vậy
đó chín vậy à
ừ ừ
à à
Ừ
thế thôi Hay các bạn trả lời sai thì các
bạn lại càng chứa Chính vì các bạn trả
lời sai nên là các bạn sẽ nhớ bài hơn
sau là những ông trả lời đúng những ông
trà đúng xong ông nghĩ Ôi bài dễ quá
mình không cần học nữa cứ thế con ông
nào trả lời sai thì sẽ nhận ra
Ý là mình đã sai đúng không Mình Minh
Thư Anh nhớ sai lầm của mình hơn nữa
ừ ừ
Ừ đúng rồi hình 1 là lấy thông tin của
cả những cái bạn không nằm trong lớp nào
Thành cho là không có thông tin lớp học
ừ ừ
Ừ đúng rồi hình chính giữa mới đúng
không là cái thứ mà mình vừa mới dậy đấy
đúng không Mình hỏi lại đúng có đấy rồi
mà
trình cái câu này ngủ chưa
39 câu này về câu roi này là lấy thông
tin đấy các bạn sẽ thấy không có không
có cái lớp nào không có sinh viên cũng
như không có sinh viên nào không có lớp
chưa Và cái cái do này chính ạ khi mà
các bạn ghi cái này nó sẽ hiểu được
những nơi rồi nó sẽ như nhau thôi chưa
ừ ừ
ạ
Bây giờ tỉnh hơn rồi đúng không
anh nghe thử hỏi lại xem trả lời đúng A
em
lấy ra sinh viên
Anh Không Thuộc lớp nào
thì là hình nào
à à
Ơ
con này dễ rồi các bạn Tịnh hơn là Nghĩa
Ừ
đấy Bây giờ thì ông công không thể bảo
được không
Em không hiểu thì anh em đúng không thấy
ông Hạn trả lời được rồi đúng không em
3000 vừa rồi mình để cho sinh viên có
thể lớp là nun thế này ra đó đúng là bây
giờ có thể sinh viên không thuộc lớp nào
có
Ừ đúng rồi các bạn sẽ thấy là bây giờ là
cái thứ đề cập liên quan đến cái câu
truy vấn nữa đây hình khi Số 4 đúng
không nó nét cho chưa thì cái cái mình
mình chưa chưa ghi con này vội mà mình
sẽ vì mình sẽ thử nói nốt về cái vụ nên
thấy cái câu này nó sẽ trả lời cho bài
toán làm đủ ngon Đây là bài toán à
em lấy ra tất cả thông tin sinh viên kèm
lớp của họ nếu có thì nó chuẩn nhất này
đúng không lấy là
thông tin sinh viên
kèm lớp kèm thông tin lớp cho mặt
Nếu có hẳn cái này
Em ngủ chưa
từ khi nó mới phù hợp cho cái hình rep
cho bình thường này thôi đúng không con
Nếu mà lấy ra sinh viên không thuộc lớp
nào thì các bạn sẽ thấy là nó nó bản
chất là
về bản chất là nó hai thằng này nó sẽ
không lấy cái phần giao thì đương nhiên
sẽ lấy cái phần Đứng yên à thừa ra đúng
không ạ
Ừ đấy thì mình sẽ có câu truy vấn ở đây
thôi Mình sẽ thử
sao con sinh viên này
nét cho đúng không nét do gì nó sẽ hiểu
là
là ưu tiên hàng bên trái Lấy toàn bộ
hàng bên trái Lấy toàn bộ thảm bên trái
Đấy cái khái niệm về led cho này chưa
Đấy on lớp chấm Mã thư ra Các bạn thấy
thì ra cái đoạn choi này thì vẫn copy
giống giống nhau thôi
Ê bà Thậm chí các bạn hệ đội sinh viên
anh trước như thế này và lớp ra đằng sau
như này nó vẫn nhận nó không đi sai cả
cái việc khai báo kệ on này kéo các bạn
đổi về với nhau đấy
ở trong trong lập trình thì có bạn sẽ
thấy à Thế ra nó chảnh hưởng gì cả Vẫn
là so sánh việc hàng ngày cũng có bằng
hài không nên các bạn để thằng nào đứng
trước hàng nào không quan trọng chưa
Nhưng mà bên này một khi các bạn khai
báo led hai à Pride rồi tự nhiên nó sẽ
quan tâm đến việc thằng nào được khai
báo trước là nào chưa ạ
Ừ nếu các bạn chỉ chạy như này Nếu mình
vẫn nói nếu mà chỉ chạy như này thì sẽ
là lấy trong ra thông tin sinh viên kèm
thông tin lớp Nếu có nên mình chạy thử
các bạn xem này
Ừ đấy thì các bạn sẽ thấy là có lo Sky
này thì không có mạng lớp bạn lớp đang
là trống nên nó sẽ không ra lớp nào lớp
đấy sẽ luôn luôn đúng không chưa
sau khi mình Bây giờ mình mình chính vì
mình nhìn vào cái cái cái cái này có thể
mình không cần nhìn lại cái ảnh nữa có
bạn thì vẫn chưa chưa để cái đoạn cốt ở
trong cái ảnh này đâu thì các bạn sẽ
hình dung được lại bây giờ lấy tất cả
cô sinh viên không thuộc lớp nào là lấy
các bạn Long scan này đúng không Thì
mình sẽ que
que cái gì nghe một trong ba cái cục này
Ừ nó làm ngu là được chưa nó luôn là
được
cho ví dụ là Where sinh viên
ở ngoài mà lớp đi bạn lớp này itneun là
được
anh nói ít nhá Không để bằng luôn được
Hôm trước mình có nói về cái vụ đấy Đó
là nun nó không phải là một giá trị nếu
các bạn không thể bằng được nó là các
bạn sẽ phải đã phải dùng theo cách này
ở đó thì nó xảy ra được đã được thì ngay
thôi đúng không
Ừ thì các bạn sẽ thấy da
vì Nếu giả sử em không muốn dùng cột mã
lớp em muốn dùng cột mã này hai tên này
thì sao
Ừ thì các bạn sẽ thấy nếu mà khai báo cử
như thế này nó sẽ báo lỗi bởi vì là nó
sẽ thương ai lỗi kiểu Nga khi mà các bạn
roi bảng với nhau thì nó sẽ liên quan
việc và
22 bạn này cùng cùng trùng tên cột nên
thành ra là cột mã này nó đang bị is
mình không biết là phát âm từ đúng hay
không nhé Mình cứ gọi là lá thế dịch nếu
một dịch cái này ra nó sẽ là nó là kiểu
mơ hồ cả là cột mã này đang mơ hồ không
biết được thuộc cái bảng nào chỉ các bạn
sẽ phải khai báo rõ là thuộc bạn sinh
viên này Ừ nếu mà như thế này thì rất là
nó không không có sinh viên nào
em mãi là nôn cả bạn lớp thì mới có ngày
trở lại
à mà lời khuyên của mình khi mà để mà
lấy sinh viên không thuộc lớp nào như
thế này đúng không khi mình sẽ thường
hay lấy trên chính cái cột mà mình dùng
để roi chiếc cột này thì cho mình sẽ
luôn thường anh ấy cột này để mà để mà
xác định được lấy toàn bộ những cái
thằng ở bên trái thừa ra mà thằng bên
phải không có không có cái dao này đây
mình sẽ lấy
ừ ừ
em đi chưa các bạn hãy ra thời ra buổi
hôm nay
đến đây là gần ngừa xong về cái cho rồi
cái thứ mà thực sự là hôm qua đã có vài
bạn
bài học sâu hơn rất nhiều rồi Bạn ấy
cũng hỏi lại mình về vụ do này thì cấp
bạn đấy không nắm rõ gì cho lắm nhưng
mình khi mình chia sẻ xong cái ảnh này
các bạn đấy thì các bạn đều
anh đều làm được
Ừ thế này đã đủ à Không cái này chưa lùn
đâu mình khẳng định này chưa nỗ lực khó
đâu Cái chỉ có mới mình nghĩ là đang mới
chứ nó vẫn chưa lỗi là kiểu phải đau não
lắm
Ừ cái này lại liên quan đến đau lão đâu
không Cứ bình tĩnh mẹ chưa nỗi đau lão
không
Khi nào đến đoạn đau não thì mình sẽ
khẳng định các bạn đau não khi mà liên
quan nhiều bạn khẳng định là sẽ long não
Ở đây có về vụ mà các bạn nó muốn xin
ảnh hay xin các thử nhé Thì cái thứ cá
tra trên mạng người ta có đấy nhớ có do
ấy
ở đáy nồi giòn là do da ngay đầu nhưng
mà thiệt mà chữa kia chưa chắc này đấy
mà mình thích nhất của kìa Ảnh này mình
thấy là nó ghi các câu lệnh khá ổn so
với những cái ảnh khác
hỗ trợ
ừ ừ
Ừ đúng rồi cái việc khó đây là khi mà nó
làm liên quan đến việc nhiều bạn thì các
bạn sẽ bị lú hơn
Vì thế nên là các bạn để ý cái tiêu đề
của buổi hôm nay nó có gì đặc biệt đâu
nó nối bạn nhưng phần 1 Đúng
ở phần 2 Những buổi sau thì mình sẽ dạy
các bạn được nó có lúa hơn Đúng nghĩa là
việc là mình nối rất nhiều bạn
ở tập 9 3 4 bảng 34 bảng của Mỹ đã sử
dụng là
Khi bữa trước mình làm dự án nối tầm 67
vàng Chị bình thường
và đương nhiên nối như bạn như thế nóng
sẽ thú thật thì nó không tốt cho người
nào mà kiểu chưa quen nhưng mà khi mình
đã hiểu rồi mình nói như bạn có ảnh
hưởng gì cả
các bạn Hoài Đức nói về khái niệm
selexol for các thử thử phẩy phẩy như
thế Nó không phải là do đâu mà chuyện là
nối với nhau nối giá trị với nhau
đã
xát xát bên cạnh nhau thôi chứ không
không có sự liên kết vì dự án mấy thằng
đấy cả
cho nên nên nó nó không phải ảnh
ẩm thực an là
Ừ đúng rồi nó nó không nó không phải cho
à à
ừ ừ
hệ thống kê Thế bây giờ tranh thủ mà
thực ra kiến thức hôm nay nếu và các bạn
vào hơi choáng thế người ta mà mình cũng
anh cũng đủ kiến thức là mã do mình sẽ
định nói qua tranh thủ nói một chút thôi
chút ngọt cho các bạn về cái vụ là mình
áp dụng và cách tìm à bây giờ xử làm
thêm vụ thống kê hôm trước đi học em ạ
là mình đến xem là có bao nhiêu sinh
viên nó ngon đến số lượng
cô
sinh viên trong một lớp thôi ạ Ừ đúng
ở trong từng lớp đi cũng được Chừng lớp
nhé Hãy trong một lớp hai cái gì đó
không
cho dù ở trong lớp lập Trinh chẳng hạn
thế đúng không Hoặc là đến số lượng
sinh viên không thuộc lớp nào chẳng hạn
thế
hoặc cả đến
gì gì đó nữa vân vân có rất rất nhiều
Anh ta nói về một đến rồi nhé thậm chí
là đếm số lượng sinh viên nữ sinh Việt
Nam trong lớp ABC kẻ nào thì mình làm
như nào giả sử đây nhá
thì mình cứ làm đầu tiên thì để mà làm
được cái câu con này trước đi
vì số lượng sinh viên trong lớp lập
trình các bạn sẽ thấy là
Ừ nếu mà nó trong lớp 1 thì nó cũng dễ
đúng không Vì sao về hôm trước mình học
về cao là đến đây cao sự cao sao nhé
form sinh viên này à
a Where
mã Love chỉ bằng 1 trở nặng
chị đã xong gia sư của mình có chạy
trước này các bạn dễ hình dung với lại
bà trước này Đây là cố Tổng cộng là bốn
sinh viên đúng không trong một lớp là
một thì mình sẽ chỉ có hai sinh viên nằm
trong lớp 1 thôi đúng không Nhưng mà
ở đây ở trong lớp lập trình cơ ngã mình
sẽ phải nối với mạng I do I đến cái bảng
love sau đó thì mình que tên lớp bằng
lập chính thì nó mới đúng mình lấy sẽ là
roi lớp pin sẽ không dùng nét do ở đây
phải sao
a baby hiển nhiên khi mà nối lớp lập
trình rõ ràng là là sinh viên phải thuộc
nằm nằm trong một lớp ở đấy rồi đúng
không là hình số 3 rồi đúng không Mình
mình không cần phải dùng hình số 1 làm
gì cả không dùng dep troi vì rõ ràng là
sinh viên nằm trong lớp lập trình mà
đúng không Mình dùng luôn à eloy thôi
khi
con
lớp chấm Mã
vì sao mình cứ copy ở trên này ngay nhé
A và mình sẽ quen lớp chấm Tên này bằng
lập trình ra xong
em có các bạn sẽ thấy là nó vẫn ra là
hai thôi nhưng mà làm như thế này thì
còn còn ổn theo kiểu là mình có thể nó
đổi sang an toàn thông tin em ạ
công nghệ sĩ đang làm một này hoặc là
a
hacker mũ trắng chả hạn thế đúng không
chị sẽ ra là không ạ bởi vì chưa có bạn
sinh viên nào nằm trong lớp này mà đúng
không
ừ ừ
Ê bà thậm chí là các bạn nhớ về cái vụ
hôm trước về cái Good bye nhóm đấy mình
sẽ nhóm theo lớp trầm mã hàng ạ
em đang live
Ừ để mình lấy được
anh ở đây ở đây nói qua một chút nhé
ừ ừ
ờ ờ Nếu ngò mới học lớp cho mã này các
bạn sẽ thấy Ok ở đây lấy ra được
như này nhưng mà các bạn sẽ không hiểu
lắm nhưng sẽ thử C lách ở đây cho bạn
xem này
à à
anh ở đây sẽ thấy là a mã mã lớp và hai
tất cả lớp an toàn thông tin thì có một
sinh viên này đúng không
mã
số sinh viên à
I ng â
ở đây mạng lớp là hai có một sinh viên
lớp 1 thì có hai sinh viên nào ngon
Ừ
nhưng mà do là mình đang dùng ít nữa rồi
Thế nên là mình sẽ không lấy ra được
sinh viên không thuộc không lớp nào hay
là hay là lớp không chừa bạn sinh viên
nào ngon da sử bây giờ trong trường hợp
này mình muốn sử dụng tí đi thì mua giúp
doi.doi thì mình sẽ lấy được Cả lớp
không nhưng trời sinh viên nào nữa Chẳng
ạ
ý nghĩa sẽ ra nha à
nếu các bạn thấy ở đây nó bị sai đúng
không
các bạn nó hợp trước rồi cấp bạn biết
được cách sửa cái sai nào ạ
ý là rõ ra lớp thứ ba này đúng không
nước thứ ba này không có sinh viên nào
Tại sao đây là vẫn ra là 1
em có bạn nào trả lời được câu nào
ừ ừ
à à
Ở đây có
em có lớp thứ ba không có sinh viên nào
đúng không em Tại sao đến ra vẫn là một
à à
Anh nói rồi nhà ông
đúng 9 giờ tắt máy nghỉ hết rồi
ừ ừ
Ừ đúng rồi
ở trận bạn kia cho nó lấy mà có nôn rồi
nhưng mà ạ
em không có sinh viên luôn nhé nhưng mà
nó cứ đến đúng không đúng rồi cao sao và
nó cũng đến kể cả cho dù nó nun
Ừ đúng rồi đấy bạn Trời đúng không Bây
giờ mình sẽ thử xà lách ra không dùng
cao nữa nhé
Vì sao rồi chị ạ cũng không dùng Goodbye
thì các bạn xem qua có lại sẽ thấy này
các bác sĩ da này các bạn sẽ thấy là
trong trường hợp này thì không có sinh
viên nào nên nên là
ở
lớp Nó tồn tại nhưng mà sinh viên này
trống này nhạc đúng không Thì khi mình
cao ấy thì nọ nếu mà cao sao Mẹ từng nói
vụ cao sao khác gì cao cụ thể tên cột
cao sao nó sẽ ý luôn nó sẽ luôn đếm xem
là cái hàng đấy có hành 20 đến theo Hà
em tính sao đến theo bạn ghi chứ nó
không đến nghe là cụ thể một đấy nó có
trống hay không
ý thì cái khái niệm ở đây là mình sẽ
phải đến cái cột nào chấm không về cột
mà lớp à cột mã ở trong mảng lớp chống
được mà cụt mã lớp chống hoặc mã sinh
viên chồng này là thường nhé nhưng mình
vừa nãy có nói đó là mình nên theo quy
tắc là theo quy tắc À roi dựa trên cột
gì thì mình mình lấy cột đấy làm tiêu
chuẩn để kiểm tra chống được chưa Thì
mình sẽ phải là cao sinh viên Trần mã
lớp chồng như thế này Tại mình sẽ thử
các bạn đó thì bây giờ nóng sẽ ra kết
quả đúng không ạ
ừ ừ
Ừ có thì các bạn sẽ thấy à Ok trong
trường hợp này thì mời mười là đếm được
chuẩn số sinh viên nằm trong lớp cũng
chưa
Sau đó các bạn thấy là đây là toàn bộ
kiến thức mới
em mới bởi vì buổi gần yêu buổi nào mình
cũng tập như mình sẽ dậy luôn kiến thức
mới và nó
Ừ nó động lại kiến thức cũng khá lời từ
đổi ý rồi đúng không
ừ ừ
cho nên nên là các bạn sẽ thấy nó mới nó
có thể hơi choáng một tí ngờ buổi buổi
sau mình sẽ kiểu gì mình xin nhắc lại
gần cái cho này nhưng các bạn yên tâm
không hẳn này thoáng Quốc hội đâu không
Ừ thôi tạm biệt tạm bên thế này rồi nghỉ
không các bạn lại cho anh quá chết
anh như thế câu 2 sao này chắc là để
buổi sau nữa mình dậy nha à à
à Vì sẽ áp dụng luôn cau hay sao nào
à à
thì mình sẽ cân nhắc xem có nên dạy 22
địa chỉ 3 buổi thì cho bạn thấy nó dễ
hơn không
ừ ừ
I have Mình tranh thủ chia sẻ ở
ở biển đầu giờ mình hứa về cái vụ tao
Ken nhỉ
Ừ ok này có khi ở cũng choáng đấy nhưng
mà cũng khá hay có công thử xem nhé
ở top game you know Tokyo mình sẽ chia
sẻ trang của anh Mạnh Tuấn
ừ ừ
Ừ từ 7 đến xóa sư video nhé
Xem phim sex trực tuyến ý
Hãy Đợi Đấy
anh không biết ở các bạn xem video này
và anh bầy chưa
Ừ
chị bé Mở chìa khóa tìm kiếm trên Google
là một thành mở rộng được cô trong 15
phút tôi có thể dễ dàng đăng nhập vào
tài khoản Facebook của những người lạ
mặt mà tôi chưa từng gặp qua video này
tôi muốn cho các bạn thấy tự rủi ro khi
sử dụng các trang web ôtô này
[âm nhạc]
lúc được lúc không đến lớp thấy cái bột
trước rồi Cái bên nhau chỉ kịp âm hơi
muốn ta nghĩa vụ trên đây một hộp nên
mới mắt cho mình cấm rơi thả một này
khói vào trong nuôi con đi chơi không
lạnh mà lòng như đông lấy bút và mực như
là thơm lòng em ơi Cảm Xúc Có còn như
không người nào đó cho tao vay mượn chết
trong đêm say được sống những ngày vừa
qua và nơi chỉ cần phải lượng nhắm mắt
chẳng biết trước điều gì cho đỡ buồn đi
lại đi nó quyền tự do
của như là mưa trên những mái tôn anh đã
vỡ vùng trước khi kịp đưa em những cái
hôm thì cùng anh một đêm cùng anh một
lần như là người chê anh
em mình giải thích qua một tí anh ấy à
Em làm ở đây thao tác thì các bạn hình
dung nhưng mà sự không giải thích rõ các
bạn về những cái này thì mình sẽ giải
thích một tí đầu tiên thì anh ấy có tra
trên Google cái kẻng đoạn kia để mà để
ra những cái bài đang công khai của
người ta đăng nó có chưa có đoạn to khen
mà người ta không biết là cái tóc em nó
là cái gì cho quen thì lúc đầu mình có
nói nó cái khóa cái để mà mình thường
hay lấy cái ví dụ nó dễ hiểu hơn một tí
nó là như cái thẻ
Anh Hải à
em ở công ty các bạn thể ra vào công ty
các bạn
cho nó giống như khoáng khóa cửa nhà có
bạn được nhưng mà ý mình có thể công ty
tại sao bởi vì nó như thế này
Ờ bảo vệ không nhớ mặt hết tất cả các
bạn thành ra là
thì các bạn chỉ cần có thẻ và các bạn sẽ
vào được như cái chỗ của các bạn và tiếp
tục được công việc các bạn Tại sao phải
đi cập về cái vụ vào chỗ các bạn bởi vì
đưa như các bạn không thể dùng thẻ các
bạn mình vào chỗ người khác rồi mà có
thể làm được toàn bộ quyền các bạn ở
trong không đi Đấy được thừa hưởng toàn
bộ luôn các bạn chỉ cầm đúng cái thẻ đấy
được thì cái Token này nó nó là như thế
bà từng tùy nếu mà các bạn chuyên sâu
hơn người bên bên mạng Facebook tìm hiểu
lầm Facebook các thứ thì các bạn sẽ biết
được là còn tùy từng Tok em nó sẽ còn
những cái quyền dở thứ
các quyền khác nhau cơ
thì cái Bakugan mà anh ấy đang đi cập nó
Token khen hiện và khái niệm full quyển
từ cả có toàn quyền để làm mọi thứ toàn
quyền ở đây nó sẽ khái niệm đăng nhập
được Vào nick các bạn và làm được rất
nhiều thứ
anh nói chung là nó với nó như là nick
chính luôn rồi nhờ nghĩa là đang không
cần qua mật khẩu không cần
Đây
rõ Còn đây là cái cái cái tool của chính
làm Facebook nó hỗ trợ để kiểm tra xem
Token này đang có quyền gì Và nó đã hết
hạn đấy chưa Vân Vân Vân Vân đây đây thì
anh nghỉ lấy cái bài đăng này thì đúng
cái tóc cái này May mà nó hết hạn rồi
đấy nó báo lỗi này một trên
30 tiếng mãi còn mưa trên mãi một giấc
mơ mưa trên mắt
[âm nhạc]
ông
thì đây các bạn sẽ thấy là cái này nó
không bị màu đỏ nữa
Ừ cái này là tàu quen phân quyền theo
kiểu là của chính Hằng ạ của cái app là
Facebook Messenger
em chưa đi
a và và cái này Thực ra là iPhone hay
Android là quan trọng quyền nó vẫn tương
đương nhau thôi mà Cái quan trọng ở đây
các bạn ý thêm cái dòng này nữa nó cái
giọng xbike là bao giờ hết hạn vào đây
nó sẽ level nó không bao giờ hết hạn mua
khi các bạn bị lộ rồi tao ghen này ra
thì
Ừ thì các bạn sẽ thấy mà không mời hả gì
cả một lên Và thậm chí là lên mua chứ
anh ấy có so sánh ở đây Các bạn thấy là
anh người đang bài này là 217 ở trong
cái đó cái bài đăng của người đang bài
này 2016 là Sau đó một năm có kèm này nó
vẫn còn hiệu lực bởi nó không mới hết
hạn mà đúng không thậm chí
vài năm nữa không thấy lạ
anh
về đây có có rất nhiều bạn hạn chế cả
bạn thân mình từng bị đó để lộ to cat ba
khi bị lộ trong trường hợp nào Đôi khi
các bạn có thể làm vào những cái đường
link trang web lạ Các bạn đăng nhập thì
nó cũng thường anh nó sẽ xuất ra một cái
các em hoặc là các bạn dùng đầy đầy Ông
còn tự đưa tao quen cho một cái trang
kiểu autolike hai khách khủng dự để mà
tăng lượt theo dõi các thư thư
đề thi
Ừ thì các bạn để lộ to Ken ra rồi cách
để hủy thì các bạn chỉ có thể là à vô
hiệu hóa bách khoa để mà nó sẽ xóa toàn
bộ những cái các em cũng những cái khóa
cũ còn hiệu lực
anh vô hiệu hóa hoặc đổi đôi khi đổi mật
khẩu cũng được nhưng mà nhiều đôi khi
mình không mình không nghĩ là đổi mật
khẩu sẽ giải quyết rồi mà nên vội ạ vô
hiệu hóa xong rồi Các bạn có thể có thể
đăng nhập lại luôn Không sao cả chỉ cần
vô hiệu hóa cái lập tức là nó sẽ họ sẽ
xóa toàn bộ phiên mà nó ngon phiên đăng
nhập cũng như là mình sử to kèn Cũ rồi
không phải lo như lắm mưa trên Vãi cả là
đấy Xong rồi xong rồi ví dụ là sự thật
mà Công để nộp Again hàng ra là thằng
Nitơ nó sẽ dùng thocan của ông đôi khi
nó không cần đăng nhập vào nick ông đâu
nó có hàng nghìn người có quen cơ nó
không đăng nhập Nhìn cái nick chẳng làm
gì cả nếu mà nó cảm thấy là nick của ông
không không quan trọng với nó ngon thì
nó sẽ bán cái
I don't talk and ấy để mà cho cái ông
nào đi mua like hay đi mua Follow rồi ạ
Đấy theo mấy ông mới biết ở vụ hack like
hydro từ đâu là từ lấy lấy mấy cái tô
cân của mấy ông này đi spam người ta chứ
từ đâu nữa thì
thế nên là mấy ông sẽ đuôi khi mà bị lộn
có khen em bé Ông thấy theo dõi mày cái
fanpage lạ này hay theo dõi người lạ này
méo không ai biết
mấy người luôn cũng chưa Thấy người này
trong cuộc đời mấy ông ấy tự nhiên thấy
theo dõi người ta chứng tỏ với ông bị
lộn to đen rồi thì
Ừ Thì đấy là hồi đấy mình phải làm cái
tôn thôi đấy mình mình mình làm cái Tu
là mình hủy theo dõi tất cả mọi người
anh hai hủi thích tất cả cái chai là chỉ
thiệp
à à Cây có rất nhiều bạn inbox mình cái
vụ đấy vào la kiểu tự như em theo dõi
một đấm người lạ đưa em muốn nghỉ theo
dõi tất cả mọi người thì như thế nào đấy
xa lạ thế thì mình phải làm việc tốt như
người ta ngủ đây
[âm nhạc]
[Vỗ tay]
có mấy ông những chiếc ở đây rồi
Ghê
mỗi lần có lẽ em một sớm đầu đông bây
giờ anh sẽ thử dùng Chính cái tung của
Facebook lấy thai to scan của người kia
và để lấy thử thông tin rồi đấy xem Đấy
nói là sắp thẩm định mỗi màu hồng cái là
mình bắt cho là mình phải mẫu nấu là em
ra còn đi gọi tao không cho mày tôm lên
nữa ra được cái tạo một đời này có lẽ
các em vui vì anh chưa Đây là một minh
quá đủ cho một cuộc tình dành cho tôi
thắng mãi và anh ấy còn tự làm cái tool
à một cái accession một cái tiện ích để
nhà anh không Ừ rồi đó là có thể dùng
Chính cái tóc em để mặt đăng nhập vào
nick của người ta được không có đem về
xã ngoài chẳng được đâu rồi đắng mãi
chuyện tình vẫn Em hãy sẵn cái nanh dài
là hãy nhớ mua cho mấy cái tiếng Anh Anh
ấy đang để nói chung là để tui anh với
việc nhưng mà đừng nghe nhạc để giao
diện tiếng Anh đúng không ngờ bây giờ
các bạn thấy thử anh không nghe nè khác
và của mỗi bữa trưa vậy tôi không đi em
sẽ xin lỗi
Ừ ừ nó nhọn để nhạc không biết có bị
dính bằng không
à à
Ừ nó Các bạn thấy là sang Hàn
anh sang Hàn Quốc gia khác
anh không cần liên quan đến cả địa chỉ
IP đó bạn đăng nhập ở trang web và đăng
nhập ở một nơi khác không kể cả bảo mật
2 lớp các thứ thứ không nó không hiểu có
cảnh báo gì đấy cả nó sẽ thông qua hết
tất cả rồi mà nên các bạn thấy để lộ này
rất là nguy hiểm
Ê mày không để lộ mấy ông đề
xin mời các bạn 12 lớp 2 cái gì đấy nó
không còn ý nghĩa gì nữa
thế này vào được fanpage người ta có thể
thử đúng không
Ừ nó còn hỏi đấy có cần ghi nhớ đăng
nhập hay không
37 bơ thử thử một ông Khai Nha
ở một cái tiếng gì đó không biết luôn
rồi anh ấy Con đang xuất gỗ người ta
không
à à
tác giả vờ sang hẳn một cái quốc gia
khác đúng không đi du lịch thế giới luôn
à à
U23 tự nhiên mình há miệng fanpage không
đấy Đấy cũng là một trong những cái lý
do là các bạn thấy là đôi khi các bạn
vào fanpage hoặc cả vào cài đặt một cái
gì đó các bạn đều được hỏi lại mật khẩu
tại sao rõ ràng là mình đang đăng nhập
vào chính lúc của mình dễ Sao lại còn
phải họ lại mật khẩu của mình
anh Bởi vì à các bạn đôi khi cũng có thể
bị dính để lộ cô kem này cũng như là hay
là hay là có người đó ngồi ngồi vào máy
các bạn lúc đấy để làm gì đó mờ ám đúng
không thêm nên nó vẫn hỏi lại quyền một
lần nữa vẫn hỏi lại mật khẩu một lần nữa
ừ ừ
Ừ thì có bạn sẽ nói à Tao Ken nguy hiểm
như thế Tại sao bọn nói làm cái tóc em
ấy nhờ cái bài toán ở đây nó là các bạn
vừa rồi thấy để kỹ vườn nãy mình có đề
cập ở ngay đoạn này đó là
a Token này cho cài á
ở đây
a cho Facebook Messenger for iPhone hoặc
là Facebook Messenger Facebook
a cho Android vân vân thì họ sẽ thấy là
cái Token này nó sinh ra lại cho chính
mình gáp điện thoại
thì nó sẽ khi mà các bạn đăng nhập rồi
nó sẽ nha
để lưu lại
Là một cải nó sẽ sinh năm cái tóc em còn
lưu lại sẵn trên máy các bạn và các bạn
sẽ mỗi khi mà vào máy các bạn không cần
phải đăng nhập lại đúng không cần phải
đăng nhập lại
vì nó không thể lưu lại mật khẩu trên
máy các bạn rồi nó thực ra là
Ừ tao không thường anh không làm thế mà
nó sẽ thông qua mình cái tóc em này để
làm việc đấy
và nó sẽ gửi các em lên để lấy thông tin
để mà nói chung làm mọi thứ qua cái áp
nhà có kem thì nó vẫn luôn phải có Chẳng
qua các bạn không được phép để lỗ thôi
ừ ừ
Ừ đúng rồi các bạn chỉ cần vô hiệu hóa
tài khoản được các bạn đăng nhập lại là
xong
du lịch sử đăng nhập lịch sử đăng nhập
thì mình nhớ không lầm mình thì như mình
vừa đề cập đó là cái Token này nó không
hề báo cho các bạn đã đăng nhập lại nối
lạ đúng không Bởi vì cái to Kem này nó
thưa anh dán luôn địa điểm
anh hoặc là
anh nói chung là nó là địa điểm
cũ các bạn đấy à
bộ phim khi mà các bạn Nói chung là xuất
rồi Tao quen này ra từ đâu đấy nó sẽ gắn
liền kèm theo bé location thì địa điểm
cũ nhưng thành ra là
cái này hình như là không nó sẽ nó sẽ
không hiển thị lịch sử mới gì gì đâu
Ừ em
à à
Ê mấy ông bây giờ đi ngồi Mua tao kèn
thứ ba b Token Facebook khó bị lộ hơn
rồi
Ừ
Chứ cái vụ đặc biệt Sau Cái vụ mà để thì
như thằng hacker nó lợi dụng người lỗ
không Nó ngồi mò được à
hai triệu 55 triệu nộp do 5 triệu và
Token của người dùng hay 50 triệu thì
nhớ thế
anh ta nghe là trong đêm đấy Tất cả mọi
người đều bị vô hiệu hóa tài khoản đều
bị đăng xuất ra
ạ sau đó thì nó xóa luôn cái tính năng
tạm thời hồi đề nó xóa cái tính năng xem
trang cá nhân bằng tư cách của người
khác
ở tại sao hồi đấy nó thằng Facebook nó
làm nó lại bị Hơi bị cái này là là mình
đang dùng cái á
ở chung cái web này để mà sang truy cập
sàn nước ngoài thì ra là nó bị tiếng
sang nước ngoài luôn
anh nói cho các bạn biết cái vụ mà
Facebook của thuộc tính năng là xem
trang cá nhân của mình nhưng mà với mới
góc nhìn của người khác không Đấy thì
ngồi đấy hoặc Facebook tự nhiên lại
chẳng hiểu sao trong cái bạn cốt của nó
xem suốt đấy ẩn conduce em suốt đấy nó
có luôn cả cái tao quen của cái người mà
mà bạn đang xem ví dụ là sử là mình xem
trang Ân mình với tư cách của anh Mạnh
Tuấn ở ạ đúng không encanto Lại thấy
luôn to kem của anh Mạnh Tuấn thói quen
nếu còn tôi quên full phần quyền luôn ạ
ạ thì ra là
Anh thành ra là cầu khi đấy thằng hacker
nó tự nhiên mò được rối loạn đấy rồi nó
chạy con boss lấy hơn 5 triệu 250 triệu
ấy to kèn của người dùng
Anh thành ra là
ạ sau đêm hôm đấy là xong Facebook nó
phải vô hiệu hóa hết tất cả tài khoản
đăng xuất hết tất cả tài khoản ra để mà
xóa Token
anh làm sao để dầu tóc em à Không thực
ra là các bạn không đăng nhập vào trang
web lạ cũng không giống như ạ Hồi đấy
còn lấy lấy tao kem bản thân rễ Còn bây
giờ ông muốn tự lấy màn cho các bạn ơ ca
con hơi khó cơ thì hơi khó để lấy để mà
đi lộ ra ngoài cơ khí
Ừ thế thì tra bệnh vừa rồi mình nói qua
với góc nhìn của mình nó ngu chia sẻ
thêm một tí kiến thức cũng liên quan đến
công nghệ một tí cho bạn nào không phải
dân công nghệ hoa cài kể cả dân công
nghệ rồi nhưng mà chưa biết đúng không
Đây cũng khá hay mà ngon cái gì
À hôm nay sẽ có một tí bài tập
có thể có liên quan đến cái buổi nói
chuyện hôm nay cũng họ cũng ngoài Và
thậm chí là có thêm một vài cái câu hỏi
nữa dị nữa trong phần trách nhiệm nhé để
các bạn trả lời cho vui nhé
ừ ừ
ờ ờ
tạm Thế Âm Nhạc Còn bây giờ thực ra là
cũng
Ê hồi lâu rồi Để mình sẽ trả lời các câu
hỏi vào buổi sau nhé
Ừ em
Ừ Ok chào các bạn
à à